Welcome to another Game of Thrones prequel
video in which we continue to talk about its
main characters, this time about Aegon ll
Targaryen.
If you watched any of my previous videos,
you probably know when and what about this
Game of Thrones prequel series is going to
be about, but for those that don't,
let me explain it to you in short notes:
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022. It’s based on George RR
Martin’s book Fire And Blood volume 1
and on Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And
Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, the creator
of the Iron Throne,
and goes on to recount the generations of
Targaryens who fought to hold that iconic
seat,
all the way up to the civil war that nearly
tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1. The yet unreleased
Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, the war
with Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King
and Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen
dynasty.
The key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
This summer it was reported and recently confirmed
by Entertainment Weekly that HBO has released
a casting call for Prince who will become
King Aegon ll Targaryen, a key figure from
this time period of the Dance of the Dragons.
The casting call describes him: “Princess
Rhaenyra’s younger half-brother who challenges
Rhaenyra’s claim to the throne, igniting
a civil war.”
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers.
George R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne.
When people started declaring for one of them
or the other, their fight divided the kingdoms
in two. Targaryens fought Targaryens, brothers
fought brothers, dragons fought dragons.
By the time it was over, thousands were dead.
The conflict would prove to be incredibly
destructive for not only House Targaryen,
but large parts of Westeros as well. In addition,
it devastated Targaryen's dragon population,
ultimately leading to their extinction within
a few decades. They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive.
The majority of these died during the civil
war called the Dance of the Dragons,
which began in 129 AC and lasted until mid
131 AC.
One of the main characters in this series
is going to be Prince Aegon who will become
King Aegon ll Targaryen. He was named by his
mother after Aegon the Conqueror.
He's called Aegon the Usurper by supporters
of Rhaenyra Targaryen,
and Aegon the Elder to distinguish from Aegon
the Younger, Rhaenyra's son.
Aegon II Targaryen was the sixth Targaryen
king to sit the Iron Throne, succeeding his
father,
Viserys I Targaryen, as Lord of the Seven
Kingdoms. His ascent was disputed by his older
half-sister, Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen,
who had been their father's designated heir.
Aegon and Rhaenyra fought for the throne in
the civil war the singers called the Dance
of the Dragons.
His dragon was Sunfyre, also known as "the
Golden".
During the Dance, Aegon took a three-headed
golden dragon for his personal sigil
instead of the red three-headed Targaryen
dragon, indicating his mount.
Aegon's supporters used his personal heraldry
as their battle-flag.
He wore the iron-and-ruby crown of Aegon I
Targaryen and carried Blackfyre,
his namesake's Valyrian steel sword.
Aegon was severely injured during the Dance
of the Dragons, which left him bent and twisted.
At Rook's Rest, Aegon broke his ribs, his
hip, and was burned on of half his body,
most severely on his left arm. His burns turned
to scars,
and his subsequent use of milk of the poppy
gave him a puffy face.
Later at Dragonstone, Aegon broke both his
legs and was for the remainder of his life
unable to walk.
Although he was not the first child of King
Viserys I Targaryen,
Aegon was the firstborn son of King Viserys
and Queen Alicent Hightower
when she gave birth to him in 106 AC. Aegon
II had two younger brothers, Prince Aemond
and Prince Daeron, as well as a sister, Princess
Helaena.
As per traditions of House Targaryen, Aegon
would marry his sister Helaena in 122 AC.
Together, Aegon and Helaena would have three
children.
The twins Prince Jaehaerys and Princess Jaehaera
were born in 123 AC,
and Prince Maelor was born in 127 AC. None
of his children lived to adulthood,
and his line ended with Jaehaera's death in
133 AC.
Although he was Viserys' eldest son, Viserys
had named his eldest child and daughter his
heir,
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, Aegon's half-sister.
Rhaenyra and her children by Ser Laenor Velaryon
and Prince Daemon Targaryen
were to come before Aegon's own, conflicting
with precedents set by the Great Council of
101 AC.
Rhaenyra had officially been appointed as
Viserys's heir in late 105 AC,
with hundreds of lords and landed knights
having done obeisance to her
and having sworn solemn oaths to defend her
rights.
In his life, King Viserys named Rhaenyra his
heir and his will after his death stated the
same,
he wanted his eldest child, Princess Rhaenyra
to succeed him.
The ensuring debate and struggle over the
succession gave birth to the Dance of the
Dragons
when Viserys died in 129 AC.
Ultimately, Aegon II reigned as a king, although
he would be succeeded by Prince Aegon the
Younger,
his nephew by Rhaenyra and Daemon.
Relations at court began to escalate as lords
began to side with either Alicent or Rhaenyra,
with many favoring the laws established at
the Great Council of 101 AC,
declaring that the Iron Throne could not pass
to a woman.
The two parties soon became known as the "greens"
and the "blacks",
the former consisting of those in favor of
Aegon inheriting the Iron Throne,
while the latter favored Rhaenyra.
When King Viserys I Targaryen died in 129
AC, Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen was still
the heir to the Iron Throne. Since she was
pregnant at Dragonstone when her father died,
the greens in King's Landing hid the news
of Viserys's death, keeping the king's body
in his room for seven days,
until their preparations for Aegon's coronation
were complete.
With the exception of Lord Lyman Beesbury,
the small council agreed to crown Aegon.
According to Mushroom, the prince was found
with a young girl in Flea Bottom,
while Septon Eustace claimed Aegon was found
abed with a paramour, the daughter of a trader.
According to Eustace, Aegon at first refused
to be a part of his mother's plans to crown
him,
insisting Rhaenyra was heir. However, Ser
Criston Cole, Lord Commander of the Kingsguard,
convinced him that should Rhaenyra take the
throne, Aegon and his brothers would be executed.
Eustace insists that only this persuaded him
to take the crown.
On the tenth day of the third moon of 129
AC, the death of King Viserys I was finally
announced to the Seven Kingdoms and Aegon
was declared a king.
Preparations were made to have the coronation
at the Dragonpit.
On the appointed day, Ser Criston the Kingmaker
placed the crown of Aegon the Conqueror upon
the prince's head, proclaiming him King of
the Andals, the Rhoynar, and the First Men.
However, King Aegon faced the first betrayal
the same day when Ser Steffon Darklyn of the
Kingsguard fled to Rhaenyra at Dragonstone
with the crown of Viserys I.
Rhaenyra refused to be denied her crown, disputing
Aegon's ascension.
Aegon enjoyed the wealth of King's Landing,
Oldtown, and Lannisport,
as well as the support of Houses Hightower,
Lannister, and Baratheon.
He also maintained the appearance of legitimacy,
with the Conqueror's crown,
the Valyrian steel sword Blackfyre, and the
Iron Throne.
Upon hearing of Rhaenyra's coronation, Aegon
demanded the heads of her and Prince Daemon,
although Grand Maester Orwyle convinced Aegon
to allow him to
give peace terms to Rhaenyra.
However, Rhaenyra refused the terms, much
to the anger of Aegon.
The realm was split in two as the greens and
the blacks battled for the Iron Throne,
and the civil war known as the Dance of the
Dragons began.
Early in the war, Prince Aemond slew Prince
Lucerys Velaryon over Storm's End,
while Lucerys was attempting to win Borros
Baratheon, Lord of Storm's End, over to his
mother's side. Upon Aemond's return, having
ensured Storm's End's support, Aegon welcomed
his brother with a great feast, although Queen
Alicent and her father, Ser Otto Hightower,
the Hand of the King,
were concerned about the extent of Aemond's
actions.
Seeking revenge against Aegon, Prince Daemon
took action. Aegon's heir, Prince Jaehaerys,
was killed in the Red Keep by Blood and Cheese,
agents of Mysaria, Daemon's spymaster.
While Blood was captured and tortured to death,
Cheese who was a ratcatcher was not found.
In his fury, Aegon ordered every ratcatcher
in the city to be hanged.
While the greens suffered a series of defeats
in the riverlands, Ser Otto attempted to win
allies with letters and buying sellswords.
Aegon mistook his efforts for inaction, and
his caution for cowardice.
With House Velaryon, House Stark, House Arryn,
and many of the riverlords firmly behind his
sister, Aegon drowned his growing fears in
strongwine.
With Corlys Velaryon, Lord of the Tides, blockading
King's Landing, Otto reached out to the Triarchy
and Dalton Greyjoy, Lord of the Iron Islands,
for aid. Because of his grandfather's delays
in waging war,
Aegon stripped Otto of the Handship and awarded
it to Criston Cole.
Ser Criston soon took to the offensive.
Aegon himself took the field in a trap set
by the Kingmaker at Rook's Rest,
where he and Aemond fought and killed Princess
Rhaenys Targaryen, the Queen Who Never Was,
and her dragon, Meleys.
However, Sunfyre were badly maimed by Rhaenys
and Meleys,
and Aegon suffered from burns that covered
half his body, a broken hip, and numerous
broken ribs.
His armor had melted into his left arm, and
it would take him a year to recover.
Aemond took over the rule in his stead as
Prince Regent and Protector of the Realm.
Aegon remained bent and twisted for the rest
of his life, half his body covered in burn
scars.
Rhaenyra took King's Landing and the Iron
Throne in 130 AC,
Aemond and Daemon slew each other in the Battle
Above the Gods Eye,
and Criston perished in the Butcher's Ball.
Before they could be captured by Rhaenyra,
however, Larys Strong, Lord of Harrenhal,
secretly smuggled Aegon and his children out
of the city.
While his children were spirited away to safety,
Aegon disguised himself as one of the smallfolk
and escaped on a fishing boat, later arriving
on Dragonstone where he convinced several
blacks to defect and help him take the island.
During the fall of Dragonstone, he fought
Daemon's daughter, Princess Baela Targaryen,
both of them mounted on dragons.
When Sunfyre and Moondancer fell to the earth
during the fight,
Aegon tried to jump off his dragon's back,
shattering his legs.
Meanwhile, Aegon's wife Helaena had ended
her grief by jumping out of her room in the
capital,
and his son, Prince Maelor, was killed by
a mob in Bitterbridge.
Following the Storming of the Dragonpit, Rhaenyra
fled to Dragonstone in 130 AC.
Unaware of Aegon's coup, she was captured
on arrival, judged a traitor, and fed by Aegon
to Sunfyre,
as Rhaenyra's surviving son, Prince Aegon
the Younger, watched.
Ser Alfred Broome argued for killing Prince
Aegon as well, although the king forbade it.
However the war continued as Rhaenyra's supporters
continued her cause supporting Aegon the Younger,
despite the boy being Aegon the Elder's prisoner.
Although Rhaenyra was dead, the Dance of the
Dragons was not yet over
as those loyal to her continued the fight
in the name of her son Aegon the Younger.
The river-lords marched towards King's Landing,
while a large host from the Vale of Arryn
was hiring ships to bring them down on the
capital.
Aegon made efforts to hatch dragon eggs from
Dragonstone, but to no success.
Although Aegon II desired for his sister's
line to end;
Aegon decreed that the prince would either
join the Night's Watch or serve him as a eunuch.
With armies closing in on the capital and
his lords plotting and arguing, Aegon II remained
oblivious.
However, Kermit Tully, Lord of Riverrun, and
his army had defeated Lord Borros Baratheon
in the Battle of the Kingsroad.
With no green armies remaining, the Lads marching
on the capital,
and with the additional approach of the Valemen
and the northern army of Cregan Stark,
Lord of Winterfell, Lord Corlys Velaryon knew
defeat was imminent in 131 AC.
He counseled King Aegon to abdicate and join
the Night's Watch, but the king refused.
He instead gave orders to have the ear of
his nephew, Prince Aegon the Younger,
cut off and sent to Lord Tully as a warning.
After his meeting with the small council,
the fatigued Aegon climbed into his litter
and asked to be carried to the royal sept.
The king had his customary flagon of sweet
Arbor red along the way to ease his pain.
When his escort arrived and a Knight of the
Kingsguard lifted the litter's curtains,
Aegon II was found dead with blood on his
lips.
With Aegon II dead, Lord Corlys and an unharmed
Aegon the Younger
rode out to meet the vanguard of Kermit Tully's
host, proclaiming the king was dead.
The late king had no male heirs left, which
led to his nephew Aegon the Younger,
Rhaenyra's son, ascending to the Iron Throne.
Who exactly poisoned the king remains unknown,
although those judged responsible
were arrested for the crime during the Hour
of the Wolf
when Lord Cregan Stark took over the capital.
Even though Lord Stark was on Rhaenyra's side,
he still wanted those who broke their loyalty
towards Aegon ll punished
because they could do the same in the future
to Rhaenyra's son Aegon lll.
The main susects in Aegon II's death were
Lord Velaryon, Lord Larys Strong,
and Ser Perkin the Flea, who feared that Aegon
II remaining on the Iron Throne
would lead to continued war. Lord Stark had
26 traitors arrested, judged and punished
or spared.
It's often agreed by many that no one really
won the Dance of the Dragons,
but it's a fact that Rhaenyra's loyalists
won the war and Rhaenyra's children got the
throne.
Despite being considered as part of the Targaryen
dynasty, history would not be kind to Aegon
II,
even though it's equally unkind to his half-sister,
Rhaenyra.
Thank you so much for watching!
If you enjoyed this video please give it a
big thumbs up and I hope to see you in the
next one!
Peace!